what kind of monster would fire kermit
the frog why was one star kicked off her
own show and how did toby mcguire's
salary demands nearly end the spider-man
series keep watching to find out
steve whitmire the voice of kermit the
frog for 27 years was fired by disney in
2017 and there are at least three
different versions of why he was let go
speaking to the hollywood reporter
whitmire painted himself as the last
holdout from before disney's acquisition
of the muppets in 2004. he told thr he
was given two reasons for his firing for
being outspoken and critical about
changes to kermit and for refusing to
work on a specific project disney and
the muppet studio had a different story
they told the hollywood reporter
wittmeyer was quote overly hostile and
unproductive and claimed he had been
dismissed for patterns of behavior that
he'd displayed quote over the course of
many years
but according to gizmodo the real reason
was simple money unnamed sources told
gizmodo that whitmire had asked for a
higher salary than any other muppet's
performer first class flights to and
from his home and a separate salary for
his wife who worked as whitmire's
manager what they really wanted was for
me to frame this as i moved on
and that i had retired and i it was just
disingenuous instead they fired him and
the blame game began
following his appearance as the red
skull in 2011's captain america the
first avenger actor hugo weaving made it
clear that he didn't really want to
return to the mcu telling collider he
had quote done his dash with that sort
of film
of course he had already signed a
multi-picture deal but he seemed
confident that marvel wouldn't force him
to fulfill those obligations it turns
out he was right but it was mostly a
matter of money in 2020 weaving told
timeout marvel that he had actually been
willing to play the red skull again in
2018's avengers infinity war and 2019's
avengers end game but marvel had offered
him quote much less money than before
when the two sides couldn't reach an
agreement weaving was replaced by ross
marquan who couldn't have been more
thrilled i'm a huge marvel geek myself i
used to draw comic books when i was a
kid this is just this is all just very
amazing
the late valerie harper was a successful
sitcom star throughout the 70s she rose
to fame on the mary tyler marsha
eventually earning her own spin-off
series rhoda she let her own series
again in the 80s nbc's valerie in which
she played a mother trying to raise
three sons mostly on her own
coincidentally the series also proved an
early high point in the career of a
young jason bateman who played valerie's
eldest son david valerie proved a hit
and at the end of season two harper
decided to take advantage of the
situation figuring they couldn't make
her show without you know her according
to people she originally received fifty
six thousand seven hundred fifty dollars
per episode along with ten percent of
the show's adjusted gross profits for
season three harper asked for a
significant bump to one hundred thousand
dollars per episode and 35 of the
adjusted gross profits when nbc said no
harper stopped showing up for work
nbc came back with a counter 65 000 per
episode and 12.5
but apparently they quickly changed
their minds because she was fired after
filming only one more episode her
character was killed off and the show
was first renamed valerie's family and
eventually the hogan family harper had
the last laugh though winning nearly two
million dollars in a wrongful
termination lawsuit in court
in july 2012 jennifer lopez told the
world she was leaving her position as
judge on american idol she broke the
news on ryan seacrest's radio show on
the air just a day after aerosmith front
man stephen tyler announced his own exit
from the show at the time j lo told
seacrest she was leaving because idol
was monopolizing her time explaining i
honestly feel like the time has come
that i have to get back to doing the
other things that i have to do according
to the rap though jayla was actually
fired for demanding too much money they
claimed jayla was asking for a raise
from 15 million dollars per season to 17
million dollars but since ratings were
declining fox instead fired her of
course between her musical career her
acting and more it's doubtful jlo felt
much financial hardship in the interim
but even if she had it wouldn't matter
much she was rehired the following year
and remained a judge until the end of
the series time on fox i missed
everything about it it was really hard
for me to walk away when i did
hard to believe but toby maguire was
actually fired from spider-man 2 over
salary demands nearly derailing the
beloved franchise as recounted by screen
crush when mcguire learned how much sony
had made from 2002's spider-man his 4
million dollar payday seemed far too
small a slice of the pie so during
negotiations maguire simply didn't show
up when he was supposed to report to get
his face and body scanned for the visual
effects of spider-man 2 maguire said
that due to mild discomfort in his lower
back from an injury sustained while
filming 2003's seabiscuit he wouldn't be
able to show up for work
rather than suffer what they saw as a
bluff on mcguire's part sony fired him
and soon afterward director sam raimi
and some of the producers met with
future spidey villain jake gyllenhaal
about taking over the role maguire
reportedly had his future father-in-law
who was then vice chairman of nbc
universal helped convince sony to bring
maguire back instead
for the first six seasons of the drama
one tree hill chad michael murray played
the series main character and narrator
lucas scott but at the end of the sixth
season lucas and his wife left tree hill
north carolina with their newborn
daughter after their departure one tree
hill stuck around for three more seasons
so why did murray leave the show turns
out he was fired over money demands
after trying to negotiate a pay raise
for the show's seventh season marie then
appealed to the fans to save his job
saying they're not bringing me back next
year because they want to save money
start blogging and being pissed off
apparently whatever blogging or other
attempts were made by fans weren't
successful because the final three
seasons of the drama unfolded without
him for the most part other than a cameo
appearance part way through the show's
final season
there remains no official word on
exactly why jaime foxworth's family
matters character disappeared in the
show's fourth season beyond co-creator
william bickley saying it was for quote
budget considerations in mama's wedding
boxworth's character judy is present
then at the start of the next episode
she's gone and is basically never
mentioned again rather than recast judy
for the show's five remaining seasons
her existence was utterly forgotten one
persistent rumor puts the blame for her
departure on the doorstep of foxworth's
mother though supposedly foxworth's
mother gwyn fox demanded more money for
her daughter instead boxworth was fired
none of that has ever been confirmed
though and it may all be rumor what's
not a rumor though is the fact that
foxworth never got a job acting on
television again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]